Every little noise of them makes me feel sick
Suppose, you are knocked out enough to bear this hell anymore
Second lieutenant rally sir what is it you're after an old friend is out here captain Stan? You don't want to join them
They may have a hell of a time of it
It's just what I'm hoping for sir
You haven't been in the army five minutes have you?
Our company commander you know. Hello, Stan !
You'll find him changed
He said this company throw all sorts of rotten times big strain on a man
He used to come and stay with me my sister Margaret in the holidays
She is beautiful. She waiting for me. I don't want to see how shot I am
We won't last five minutes if the Germans attack. You'll to stay where you are for as long as you can
When's that expected? Day after tomorrow.
This waiting is like being summoned to the headmaster, they've sent us here to die
All these youngsters do not realize how unlucky they are
Or does it matter they all feel like we do
I'm glad it's you and me together
I can't stick it any longer. You think there is still living to what a man can bear. There is a job to be done my darling
I mean to come through this. So we stick at it. it's the only thing that a decent man can do